House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2 will continue from
where part 1 ended, with Rhaenyra Targaryen's
son Aegon lll's reign and will cover Blackyre
rebellions, the war with Dorne and go all
the way to the Mad King and Robert's Rebellion
that ended Targaryen dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
This summer, it was reported that HBO has
released a casting call for George RR Martin's
favorite Targaryen, Daemon Targaryen, key
figure from this time period of the Dance
of the Dragons.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
One of the main characters in this series
is going to be Daemon Targaryen.
Daemon Targaryen also known as Prince of the
City, Lord Flea Bottom and the Rogue Prince
had many titles throughout his life: Prince,
Ser, Commander of the City Watch, Master of
Coin, master of laws, King of the stepstones
and the narrow sea, protector of the realm.
Daemon was the most controversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventurer
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at a same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He was Rhaenyra's second husband, following
Ser Laenor Velaryon and she was his third
wife.
Prince Daemon was the most experienced warrior
of his time and wielded the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister. A dragon rider whose dragon
was Caraxes, Daemon declared himself the King
of the Stepstones and the Narrow Sea.
Daemon was a skilled warrior, described in
the histories as dashing, daring, and dangerous.
He was also ambitious, impetuous, mercurial,
amoral, reckless, and quick to take offense.
He is described as being as charming as he
was hot-tempered.
And it seems that HBO already found a perfect
fit for the character - Travis Fimmel whom
you might know as Ragnar from Vikings.
It's not yet confirmed that he will play the
role 100%
but it's reported by Portuguese entertainment
website
that he's in talks with HBO to play the role
of Daemon.
Daemon is a versatile character who constantly
switches between being charming and loving
to crazy and bloodthirsty, and I have to stand
by HBO's side here
as in my opinion Travis Fimmel would be a
great choice to play this George RR Martin's
favorite character from this time period.
Daemon inspired loyalty.
In 106 AC, Daemon led an army to invade the
Stepstones in the southern narrow sea, with
the support of Lord Corlys Velaryon and his
fleet, and with the use of Daemon's dragon,
Caraxes.
After conquering all but two of the islands,
Daemon declared himself King of the Stepstones
and the Narrow Sea in 109 AC, being crowned
by Corlys the Sea Snake.
By the year 120 AC Daemon married two times
and had 2 daughters, but both his wives died.
In 120 AC Daemon married again, this time
to his niece, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen.
This marriage was performed suddenly without
the knowledge of King Viserys I Targaryen
and was scandalous since neither Laena nor
Laenor Velaryon, Daemon's previous wife, and
Rhaenyra's previous husband, had been dead
for six months. According to Mushroom, it
was Daemon who arranged the death of Laenor
by paying Ser Correy to kill him, thus making
Rhaenyra available to marry.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had two sons together,
Prince Aegon the Younger born in 120 AC, and
Prince Viserys, born in 122 AC.
While Viserys I Targaryen had decreed Rhaenyra
Targaryen his heir, Ser Criston Cole crowned
Queen Alicent Hightower's son, Aegon II Targaryen,
after Viserys's death in 129 AC.
The Greens took advantage of being in Kings
Landing at the time of the death of King Viserys
and took the throne while most of the Blacks
were at Dragonstone.
At the start of the civil war called the Dance
of the Dragons, Prince Daemon had more experience
in warfare than all their foes combined. During
Rhaenyra's rival coronation on Dragonstone,
Daemon placed the crown of King Jaehaerys
I Targaryen on the head of his wife, proclaiming
her queen and claiming himself Protector of
the Realm.
Daemon led the assault on Harrenhal, capturing
the ruined castle from its castellan.
After hearing of the death of his stepson,
Prince Lucerys Velaryon, at the hands of his
nephew, Prince Aemond Targaryen,
Daemon, through his spymaster and former mistress
Mysaria, hired Blood and Cheese to murder
a son of Aegon II. Son for a son.
Daemon abandoned Harrenhal when Aemond and
Criston began marching on the great castle
with a host of greens
Instead, Daemon flew Caraxes back to King's
Landing and assisted Rhaenyra with capturing
the city.
He made his niece and wife, Rhaenyra the Queen
of the Seven Kingdoms.
Daemon challenged Aemond, waiting for thirteen
days at Harrenhal until Aemond stopped burning
the Riverlands to come face him.
On the 14th day, epic battle above the Gods
Eye finally happened.
It was an aerial duel that took place in the
skies above Harrenhal
and the Gods Eye between two of the most powerful
living dragons, Vhagar and Caraxes,
and their riders, Prince Aemond and Prince
Daemon Targaryen.
The duel was said to be a sight to see. The
sun was setting as the two dragons took to
the sky.
So bright was the Dragonfire that smallfolk
feared the sky was aflame.
When Caraxes attacked Vhagar, she ripped upon
his stomach and tore one of his wings, but
then Caraxes fastened his jaws around her
throat in a death grip.
These injuries forced them both to cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below, Daemon
dueled Aemond to the death.
As he never fastened his saddle, Daemon stood
up on Caraxes and leapt at Aemond, whereupon
he drove his Dark Sister through Aemond's
eye and through his neck, just a second before
hitting the water.
The Battle Above the Gods Eye ended in the
deaths of both riders and both dragons. Daemon
was forty-nine when he died. Unlike Aemond's
body, however, Daemon's was never found. Singers
say that Daemon lived to spend the rest of
his days in secret with Nettles, but most
historians disagree.
If you'd like to know all details about the
upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series, make
sure to watch my video named ''Game of Thrones
prequel show explained''
in which I as the title says itself - explain
everything about it,
as well as why reading the book Fire And Blood
does not mean you will know exactly what will
happen on the show.
The books are history of House Targaryen written
by a Maester
who relies on questionable sources that often
differ from one another
and even George RR Martin said that its accuracy
is not the best.
Once again, let me remind you that: Fire & Blood
is a complete history of House Targaryen
written by George R. R. Martin from a perspective
of Archmaester Gyldayn
who wrote it many decades after the events
took place.
The show, unlike the book, will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi-true, not
what might or might not have happened.
We will know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show comes out, and that's
why you cannot just read Fire And Blood book
and think you would know what actually happen
or what will happen on the show.
Daemon Targaryen will be one of the main characters
and probably my favorite, just like he is
George RR Martin's favorite.
In Fire And Blood, Gyldayn uses these words
to best describe Daemon:
''Over the centuries, House Targaryen has
produced both great men and monsters. Prince
Daemon was both. In his day there was not
a man so admired, so beloved, and so reviled
in all Westeros. He was made of light and
darkness in equal parts. To some, he was a
hero, to others the blackest of villains.''.
This is a good description of Daemon.
The best description comes from George RR
Martin
of course:
Anyways, if you want more details about the
prequel, make sure to check out that video.
Let me know your thoughts about everything:
the prequel, its characters,
especially Daemon and about Travis Fimmel
being in talks with HBO to play it, in the
comment section down below. Thank you so much
for watching and hope to see you in the next
one. Peace!